une victoire au caractère pour l'Entente
le chêne et Versailles contre Dieppe se
succédait dans la sixième journée de
Nationale 2 n'a pourtant pas été simple
à obtenir d'entrée de jeu les
yvelinoises en caisse indice zéro après
un premier temps mort l'ulcv se remet
peu à peu en ordre de marche le club
compte jusqu'à 12 longueurs de retard
mais parvient à revenir à moins de
points de son adversaire à la fin du
deuxième carton Le Chesnay Versailles
est mené 34 32 à la pause
on traverse ça et mais on voit que le
coach il a pris le temps mort on s'est
remis dedans et on a sorti sur le
parquet combien avec une autre esprit je
leur ai dit qu'il faut qu'on croit
sur nous
et qu'il faut qu'il faut se battre
jusqu'au bout parce qu'on a possibilité
de gagner cette équipe dans le troisième
carton radunovic chez Galise le LCV
prend définitivement l'ascendant sur la
rencontre l'équipe est bien en place et
Cruse progressivement son avance de 14
points les joueuses ne tremblent pas
dans le quatrième carton quant à 3
minutes de la fin Dieppe revient
seulement à 4 unités le chêne Versailles
s'impose bien le score final 60 à 53
quatrième succès de la saison pour le
club c'était vraiment une victoire
d'équipe on a été la chercher avec le
mental et parce que voilà quand on gagne
de 14 points et qu'elle revienne à 4
points et qui reste 3 minutes là c'est
mentalement on n'est pas on est pas
solide c'est là on peut tomber dans la
défaite et vraiment c'est la réaction
d'équipe qu'il faut retenir ce soir
après un mauvais départ on a su se
remettre dedans
on a bien défendu sur ce match là contre
une belle équipe qui vise la montée on a
encaissé 53 points les Yvelines sont
actuellement de la poule C de National 2
c'est la meilleure défense du groupe
avec 321 points conseils depuis le début
de la saison prochain match samedi 5
novembre face au leader
Villeneuve-d'Ascq